[Music]
now the claims of Brett Kavanaugh a
third accuser Julie sweat neck are so
outlandish that we were skeptical from
the start
now that doubt seems prescient as
numerous stories about her past have
trickled out including one from our next
guest
Richard Burnett she sweat Nick's
ex-boyfriend of seven years claiming she
threatened him and his family for more
were joined in a television exclusive by
mr. vanetti himself along with his
lawyer Marcia Hanson both of you thank
you for joining us tonight Richard what
are your motivations for coming forward
now yes I this is this has nothing to do
with political issues I mean I believe
if I came over here just to basically
tell the truth I think it's my civic
duty to do so and that's one of the
reasons why I came now you claim Richard
that Miss sweat Nick threatened you
after you broke up with her what types
of threats are you alleging right after
I broke up with her she basically called
me many times and at one point she
basically said you will never ever see
your unborn child or born child alive
and I want it you know I'm just gonna go
over there gonna kill you guys she said
she was gonna kill you yes and that that
really scared me a little bit well you
told POLITICO originally Richard that
she threatened your family and your baby
yes but you met you know the unborn you
meant the unborn child is that right
I met the unborn child that's correct I
was not a Mary at that time when this
happens did she ever discuss with you
and your seven-year relationship was
from 1994 to 2001 the issue of sexual
assault or did she mention ever having
been sexually assaulted
never never once she mentioned that to
me and I would used to talk about it
just about everything and she never once
mentioned that at all
did she have a political background egde
was she interested in politics
now that I know of you know she was
always wanted to be the center of
attention and she always went to do
something major she was trying to
impress me where everything she
basically was telling me that she was
exaggerating everything
if anybody knows Julie and the person
coming I know because I live with her
and everything that came out of her
mouth was just exaggerations and that
she never mentioned that to me at all
and it's something that I was very
surprised to hear this it's actually I
was very surprised to actually see her
making these accusations because she
have never ever mentioned that to me at
all now you filed a restraining order
in March of 2001 after these threats you
said in repeated phone calls to you
threatening you and your your unborn
child and your family but you never
followed through with it you didn't you
never prepared in court if you were so
threatened by Julie sweat neck you know
you're your ex-girlfriend then why
didn't you follow through yes and that's
that's the question that is everybody's
asking and the reason I didn't is
because you know I knew that I had to
see her again I talked to at that time
to my family and we decided not to do
anything not to follow because I didn't
wanna provoke her I didn't know the type
of person I mean I knew the type of
person is she and Julie is and I was
afraid to be honest with you so we
decided to just leave it alone in the
hopes that it will go away because at
that time the only thing that I was
concerned was my family there will be
the well-being of my family so we
decided to change her numbers I move and
that's basically what we did and reacted
that we never heard from her again and
after you came forward in that initial
interview with Politico did you hear
from any of her representatives or did
you hear from her at all not at all
not
your own credibility has been called
into question I know you know this by
her lawyer Michael avenatti he appeared
earlier tonight on CNN let's watch her
boyfriend says she can't be trusted that
it's a credibility thing sweat and it
can't be trusted I've said it three
times are any of them impressive to you
no it's ludicrous Chris first of all one
lawsuit was filed it was almost
immediately dismissed the claims by her
ex-boyfriend I mean who doesn't have an
ex-boyfriend or an ex-girlfriend that
might say bad things about him well
ex-boyfriends you know breakups are
brutal right they can be brutal in this
case yours was really what it's really
not fun but people are gonna say you
just you know you don't like her because
you you were with her for seven years
and then it you had a bad ending yeah
that's yeah like I say again before like
I said before if I know if anybody knows
Julius what Nick I know she is if you
ask me personally if I believe her I
don't believe it you know personally I
don't believe her I really don't believe
her no one knows better I mean no one
knows Julius Winnick better than me and
you know he could said it to her once
but the facts are that I know and that's
what I came here to tell the truth I
mean I know how she is well you were
with her for seven years I mean you're
describing her is like she's a total
nightmare but you spent seven years with
her why were you with her for seven
years that's true for the first couple
of years we had a nice relationship but
we weren't together for seven years
we're together
off and on for seven years yes first
couple of years we spent in about a year
and a half we spent in San Jose and then
a couple of years with spammy testa and
I was transferred to Panama and and then
I came back a couple of years later
spine anyways we were seeing each other
once in a while but the more I saw it I
mean the more I I saw a basic experience
the things that she was doing I just
didn't like I mean the fact that she was
lying to me she talked she pretty much
talked about everybody she talked about
lawsuit she was like I don't know she
was effectuated about lawsuits she was
she was trying to a 1-point I remember
she told me that she was filing a
lawsuit against harassment loss -
against American Airlines and all
lawsuits the I mean so I finally decided
this thing you know you have to stop
this lawsuit thing because it's
ridiculous she will talk to me about her
family she will do odd things about me
soup for instance every table will get
into fights she will get right in my
face and she was she was she will ask me
to hit her I mean that's just sucked
very weird and she lied a lot most of my
friends did not like her in fact I can
you know they can testify about that and
I was it was she asked you to hit she
was like hit me yes yes that was a that
I don't know that was for any minor
issues that we had she will always get
into my face and the first time I
experienced that it was like oh my god
this is just you know this is incredible
she will get right in my face that she
put that she will say hit me hit me
Richard hit me and then she will say
something like remember what happened to
my ex-boyfriend I would just walk away I
was just you know it was impossible to
lose me Richard Richard I know you've
had a you've had some financial issues
in the past and you haven't shied away
from that correct you you got underwater
on a mortgage you've had your own issues
correct that's correct like everybody
else I guess
when you watched her testify last week
when you you know she went through the
very heartfelt description of what
happened to her at the hands of what she
said was Brett Kavanaugh what went
through your mind when the rest of the
country was saying she's so credible
she's so believable
you knew her for seven years what was
going through your mind when well first
of all the way we're first heard her I
mean her name mentioned TV I thinking oh
my god
excuse me rephrase she obviously didn't
testify when you heard her come out with
these allegations of you know this
hideous attack a gang rape a sexual
assault you had been her with her for
seven years did she ever say anything
about gangrena world never never
we talked about everything she never
once mentioned this to me at all Richard
Marcia thank you so much for being with
us tonight
we'll probably try to have you back if
other things come up but we really
really appreciate it and appreciate your
time all right